うふふ
うわぁ区分けはだーっっ
こんにちははずです最近一時ハマっております従業カード皆さんやっていますからまた
今年もいう偉業カードをし世界大会につながる予選が始まるんでちょっとギャル肥満男
で後輩という乗客をやってるんですけども
遊戯王カードってこういうですねデッキで戦うんですよ40万円から60万円くらいの
母の魂で自分のデッキを作ってか手駒に弾いてたんですけども
ジュエリー
1人欠かせないもの deck デッキっていうのがもう3リストの魂みたいなもんな
んですよ
これがないと
死んでしまいますてくらいデュエリストにとってデッキって大事なものなんですけども
もしもしですよもしこのデッキがこうやってあって俺のターン
道路聞くんですけどほどの方ができなかったらどういう反応するとこっちは見て行き
たいと思いますいうわけで今日の動画は後輩のデッキをあろう another で
全部くっつけるだけ塾
後輩のデッキ or no
アルファーで全部くっつけるドッキリやっていきたいと思います安心してください母と
子たらつけるともったいないんでそんなことはしないんですけどやっぱちゃんとやっ
てる人ってカードこのまま使わないんですよ
カードを入れる3部っていうのにカードを入れて来て守って使うんですよ
さらにこの3部も傷つけたくないんで僕の周りだとこのスリーブにさらにもう一枚本が
久美子さん入れて20でガッツかつにして
こうやってやっているんでカード自体が傷つきませんとに使う後編デッキがこちらです
アーネスぽい可愛い主流使ってるんでコレレアな奴なんですよ
こういう感じで公園のデッキがあるわけでミラー4歳っていうのね赤デッキが入ってる
わけなんですけどもこれを今からあのアルファでくっつけていこうと思います
最低ですけどに柔軟でこの一番外のやつだけくっつけます
本人のやつを汚してもダメなんで全く同じやつ準備させていただきました彼のカード
スリーブすべて汚すことなくボブ熱で全部くっつけて行ってみようと思います1回全部
抜きます
スーズ部おりましたこれで全部僕のせいぶだったんでくっついでも建設は耳折れません
ご安心下さいって言うけどここからですこの天井の魂のデッキ踊ろうできない状態にし
てあげましょうこのローアイバーで
つけますやはりこういう緊張されたこれつけるのめっちゃ悪いことして気がするけど
マーカーと汚れてないんで大丈夫ショップんっ
犬用6カ所でくっつけます行けます
ん
やはりあってんだこれうわぁドールを
さてはくっつかんかさてバクッ使うのかこれってアウェーのスリーブ方6つかも
やっぱりね時間が解決する問題じゃないですあろうアルファが効かない何でも全て命
すぎるからかな全然意味がないんですよ黙ってもこっちであなたも凝ってていき
ましょう
いやー3ブルーらが特殊すぎてつかないため
ん
ぱいっ
う
たいときでとりあえず今40名ほどあっていると20万にしましたこのネジもやさらに
10枚にしていきます
入ったうえでさらにまとまりましたこれをさらに重ねてまとめていきます
はいだいぶまとまってきましたさらにくっつけていきましょう刷毛ばヒールなんか
ヤバい
ごめん形成うわあああっ入っていることもみました大集合体ですこれで元のデッキの
大きさに戻しましょう
うんてるじゃんかめっちゃ分厚くなっちゃったら最初よりちょっと押し込みます
ん
なんでこれ俺も白でお子さでプレースかけた方がいいの
しっかり大阪簡単にプレースしますねこんなとこにで気軽なと思ってねーだろ
ok ないとき出てきました今中にボンドヘッド集約ついていますすいませんあのアー
カーだったら瞬間接着剤だったんですぐできたんですけどもうちょっとこれだと特殊な
素材でくっつかなかったので時間のかかる普通のボンドでやりましたねこれ完全
に行くそこまで24時間ほどかかるのデー
明日を
お楽しみにっ
high purity
どうなってるんでしょうかこれでねやわらか甘酢で今度が終わりですからね接着剤力が
試される客ですっ
ブーバ大須釣れすぎてっ中のサッチャーた
できていますあぁこれなかなか硬いなぁ
あっはぁやばそうだねなくカード自体柔らかいもんだからコッビ c ガチガチって何
イメージだったんですけど
甲奴ちゃーっとしっかりくっついてる感じで進まなきゃダメチャットモード取得からと
いうわけで早速
道路ができないデッキでデュエルを申し込んでくる
久野祐気4さあと呼びを仕掛けていきましょう
ます
気が割れるがちょっとかで隠しながら多いときますではくるのを待ちましょう
えっ医療救急 you do 嬉しくじゃないですね
最後席を取っておいおいおいたんだ理由したの
いいね可愛いね今日もつけ応用読む
ブーブーけどだけどこれを売っちゃっあるいはプランターああっああっにょだろサティ
ドローン
[音楽]
me
バッハ
アコーディオンな音ヘヤーコルディア大魔法では何個でよねっ